[Music]
the common conception about cannabis
versus alcohol is that cannabis is safer
than alcohol and well that may be the
case for physical health that does not
seem to be the case for social and
economic problems people who are regular
users over many years ended up in a
lower social class on their parents
that means they ended up at jobs that
required fewer skills were less well
paid and were less prestigious
[Music]
for example a New Zealand the sample
that they needed sample is mostly white
so what question that could arise is
whether the same results would apply in
the US where it's more racially
heterogeneous but there's still a lot we
don't know and I think that's exactly
the kind of research we should be doing
that with the legalization both in the
United States and in other countries
[Music]
you